c'è una parola che custodisce il segreto
del progredire del mondo e della parola
cambiamento È una parola un po' magica
perché è come se fosse una matriosca ne
contiene tante altre dentro contiene la
parola paura speranza
illusione e delusione innovazione e
conservazione fascino desiderio
suggestione timore Anzi angoscia e
questo è il cambiamento e il cambiamento
può
interessarti e attraversarti da vari
angoli della vita ti può attraversare
dal lato di una gioia perché entra nella
tua vita un bambino diventi papà diventi
mamma ti può attraversare per un lutto
per un cambio radicale della tua
professione o perché decidi di fare una
cosa completamente diversa nella vita
ma analizzate dentro di voi chi non è
mai stato
coinvolto attraversato da una esperienza
profonda di cambiamento Io vi racconto
quella mia a me è successo dal punto di
vista professionale Permettetemi però
prima un passo indietro
quando il 30 maggio del 2001 Erano
passati meno di 7 anni dalla mia laurea
in università Cattolica
quando il 30 maggio del 2001 varcai per
la prima volta la soglia dell'aula di
Montecitorio Rimasi rapito guardando in
alto dai fregi del Sartorio 110 metri
per raccontare la storia d'Italia
ispirati al Partenone e ai trionfi del
Mantegna e guardando in alto incontrai
lo sguardo di mia moglie aveva il
pancione perché aveva in grembo il
nostro primogenito e aveva un vestito
rosso e
incontrando il suo sguardo trovai perché
mia moglie non è solo la mia compagna
anche la mia testimone di vita
trovai una testimonianza la
testimonianza di un qualcosa che nasceva
da molto prima da quando lei mi conobbe
e io facevo il rappresentante degli
studenti organizzavo le prime
manifestazioni Antimafia nella piccola
città in quindi sono nato e la trovai
testimone di un sentimento che provavo
esattamente in quel momento
io in quel momento
desideravo fare per tutta la vita quello
che stavo per cominciare a fare lì il
parlamentare l'uomo al servizio delle
istituzioni perché sentivo che le
istituzioni erano esattamente il luogo
in cui io potevo rappresentare ciò che
mi sentivo di essere E allora incontrai
quello sguardo e pensai in quel momento
di avere una condivisione di una
certezza stavo
realizzando coronando compiendo il mio
sogno di giovinezza avevo realizzato
esattamente quello che volevo fare nella
vita perché a me è successa una cosa che
non capita sempre e non capita a tutti
la mia passione quel che sentivo da
ragazzino era diventato il mio lavoro e
non sempre capita Non tutti a non tutti
capita
e devo dire che questa io l'ho sempre
considerata una grazia di Dio ho sempre
considerato questo un grandissimo
privilegio fare nella vita esattamente
ciò che coincide con la tua passione e
dunque in quel momento mai e poi mai
avrei immaginato che alcuni anni dopo
avrei varcato lo studio di un importante
trasmissione televisiva per dire che non
non proseguivo più che finiva lì e che
mi ritiravo mai avrei immaginato che
quella decisione la più travagliata è la
più sofferta della mia vita mi avrebbe
portato a fare esattamente ciò che mai
Avevo pensato di fare e cioè ritirarmi
dalla politica che era la mia passione e
pensate Con quanta sofferenza io assunzi
quella decisione perché ritirarmi dalla
politica per me era come ritirarmi quasi
dalla dalla vita perché l'ho fatto
l'ho fatto perché mi era finita la
benzina interiore perché quello che mi
aveva spinto era una linfa vitale e un
fuoco dentro e il tutto invece era
diventato non più una spinta ma era
diventata una spinta inerziale non una
spinta Vitale ma una spinta inerziale E
tutto quello che mi aveva animato dentro
si era un po' spento e l'ho fatto perché
mi sono reso conto in quell'istante che
nessuna professione merita di essere
vissuta nessuna professione merita di
essere svolta se non hai il fuoco dentro
di una passione che l'alimenta perché
altrimenti diventa una fatica
insostenibile E questa esperienza mi ha
insegnato una grande cosa mi ha
insegnato che quando nella vita si dice
che l'unica cosa certa sia la morte si
dice una cosa che non è vera perché
l'altra grande cosa certa della vita è
il cambiamento con una grande differenza
che
almeno per chi non crede la morte su
questa Terra è la fine di tutte le cose
mentre il cambiamento è trasformazione è
divenire e nuovo inizio e dunque
essenzialmente il cambiamento è vita e
mi sono trovato in altri video
importanti della mia carriera
a vivere esattamente Questa stessa
sensazione e viverla è stata un qualcosa
che mi ha riportato a quello che è il
profondo sentimento di chi si trova a
prendere una scelta radicale nella
propria esistenza e nella propria vita
mi sono trovato
ad avere paura della solitudine e ho
imparato a gestire la paura della
solitudine solitudine rispetto ad una
decisione solitudine nel momento in cui
devi scegliere Perché Perché per quanto
possano essere amorevoli i consigli di
chi ti vuol bene o competenti i consigli
dei tuoi consulenti alla fine la
responsabilità della decisione è solo
tua tua sarà la responsabilità della
scelta e tua sarà la decisione su ciò
che è vuoi fare della tua vita e dunque
sarà con te stesso l'ultima riunione che
dovrai convocare puoi parlare con i
parenti puoi parlare con le persone a te
più care puoi parlare con i consulenti
ma sarai tu a dover gestire quel preciso
istante di solitudine perché sarà tua
quella responsabilità bene
se non sarai in grado di gestire Quella
fase quell'istante quel momento di
solitudine allora saranno sempre le
circostanze a decidere per te o saranno
gli altri a decidere per te e poi avrai
un'altra grande paura avrai la paura per
le conseguenze delle tue decisioni
penserai ma quello che sto per fare è
meglio o peggio sto sbagliando o sto
indovinando E questa cosa che sto
facendo è veramente il meglio per me o
no
la saggezza dei filosofi antichi e la
scienza dei moderni psicoterapeuti e ci
insegna che il nucleo essenziale
dell'infelicità umana sta nel tentare o
meglio nell'avere la pretesa di
riscrivere il passato o di prevedere con
esattezza il futuro
in realtà Il passato è già andato via
Non lo possiamo riscrivere il futuro è
impossibile da prevedere L'unica cosa
che nelle nostre mani è il presente
nella sua fuggevolezza che è esattamente
il luogo in cui noi siamo chiamati a
decidere è normale avere questa paura ed
è normale avere la fatica della gestione
di questa paura Io quando ero ragazzino
amavo tuffarmi dagli scogli niente di
pericoloso Anzi Se pensate che state
facendo un tuffo pericoloso fermatevi
amavo tuffarmi dagli scogli e tuffandomi
dagli scogli ricordo esattamente
l'istante che precedeva il tuffo quel
preciso istante in cui mi chiedevo Ma
chi me lo fa fare ma qui c'è un caldo
meraviglioso ma si sta benissimo Magari
c'è anche l'acqua fredda ma io sto
benissimo ma io non mi tuffo e poi però
ricordo anche la il momento dello stacco
da terra e l'ingresso in acqua la gioia
dello stare quell'entusiasmo della
risalita Il piacere della nuotata Certo
A volte ho rinunciato a tuffarmi ma non
c'è gioia in quella rinuncia non c'è
nessuna energia in quella rinuncia Ecco
la vita e il cambiamento spesso mi
ricordano quei tuffi C'è sempre un buon
motivo per non tuffarsi C'è sempre un
buon motivo per rinunciare ma c'è sempre
tanta energia che ti fa dire io mi tuffo
solo se hai fiducia e io ho provato una
grande fiducia quando ho capito una cosa
che sì è vero mi sono chiesto ma tutto
ciò che era maturato fin lì quello che
ho fatto le mie relazioni i miei
rapporti umani le esperienze della mia
vita ciò che avevo imparato cambiando
completamente dimensione me le porto
dietro mi serviranno oppure saranno un
qualcosa che rimane lì accantonata e
tutto quello che ho fatto rimane
conservato in un archivio in un cassetto
Perché cambio completamente il mio
lavoro e non mi serviranno più mi sono
accorto che facendo ordine delle delle
sconfitte nell'evitò nelle vittorie e su
ciò che è essenzialmente mi è giovato
nei momenti di forza e ciò che mi ha
condizionato negativamente in termini di
debolezza per alcune decisioni e
mettendo ordine in tutto ciò alla fine
mi sono trovato e vi troverete con uno
zaino sulle spalle pieno di una cassetta
di attrezzi che sono le cose che avete
costruito nella vita fin lì vi sembrerà
incredibile Perché apparentemente magari
quegli attrezzi nulla hanno a che fare
con la nuova attività che tu stai
facendo e invece ti ritroverai
miracolosamente al tuo servizio perché
fanno parte di te stessa e questo è un
elemento di fiducia straordinario però
serve predisporsi al cambiamento
preparare l'animo al cambiamento se è
vero che il cambiamento Comunque arriva
tanto vale andargli incontro
prepararsi l'animo al cambiamento
predisporre l'animo al cambiamento
essenzialmente significa sapere che
tutto è provvisorio
che nulla ci è dato per sempre niente è
definitivo se tu parti con il
presupposto che quel che stai facendo
Non è definitivo il tuo animo va già
incontro al cambiamento e il segreto del
cambiamento e sognarlo costruirlo
progettarlo immaginarlo perché la vera
alternativa è patirlo soffrirlo se non
saprai gestirlo
e
se c'è un posto dove non stare seduti e
quello di stare seduti su se stessi
questo l'errore se c'è un posto dove non
stare seduti quel posto è noi stessi Noi
non dobbiamo mai stare seduti su noi
stessi a me è capitato nella vita di
gestire organizzazioni complesse di
gestire ministeri e di gestire partiti
politici mi è capitato nella vita di
avere a che fare con Prefetti generali
dei Carabinieri comandanti delle forze
militari Ambasciatori e anche capipopolo
di territorio i capi elettori si quelli
del territorio e ho imparato che non c'è
nessuna organizzazione complessa capace
di evolversi capace di andare avanti se
non è guidata e partecipata da persone
che accettino la sfida del cambiamento
che abbiano l'inclinazione al
cambiamento e questo significa non
vivere il cambiamento come se fosse il
figlio il frutto del destino ci comunque
baro di una sorte avversa che ti ha
colpito No significa leggere i segnali
della realtà coglierli e avere la
capacità di trasformare quella che
possibilmente una necessità quella di
cambiare in una opportunità per un
Progresso spirituale e un rafforzamento
della propria dimensione professionale e
devo dirvi anche che questa
predisposizione dell'animo al
cambiamento ogni tanto si può raffinare
con un esercizio
chiediamoci spesso
quel che ho già fatto e il massimo di
ciò che potevo fare quel che ho già dato
a me stesso alla mia famiglia alla
società
è esattamente tutto quello che già
potevo fare o potevo dare O potrei
ancora dare di più e potrei ancora dare
di meglio
abbiamo delle App abbiamo delle App nei
nostri orologi che ci segnalano anche
quando dobbiamo alzarci e camminare
Abbiamo delle App che ci segnalano
quando dobbiamo ricominciare a respirare
altre che ci dicono se il rapporto sonno
veglia è corretto nella nostra vita e
nella nostra notte Abbiamo delle App che
ci dicono quale l'itinerario più breve
per raggiungere la nostra destinazione
ma non ci sarà mai
un'App che ti dirà quando è giunto il
momento di rimettere in movimento la tua
vita perché hai bisogno di intraprendere
una destinazione nuova perché la tua
anima te lo richiede non ci sarà mai una
app che ti segnalerà il momento giusto
in cui dovrai trattenere il respiro per
una decisione che dovrai prendere non
troverai mai una app che ti dirà Qual è
la strada più breve per la destinazione
che il tuo spirito ti segnala come
quella giusta da raggiungere a questo
dovrai provvedere solo tu se ti sarai
preparato a farlo e se vorrai farlo Ecco
perché occorre sempre sempre tenere in
moto la nostra anima la nostra mente è
il nostro cuore perché se tu terrai in
moto la tua anima la tua mente il tuo
cuore saprai cogliere immediatamente il
momento in cui il tuo entusiasmo si sta
spegnendo e la tua partita sta
diventando noiosa Ecco perché io penso
di poter dire che la cosa più giusta è
che tu tenga sempre in movimento la tua
anima il tuo cuore la tua mente che
cerchi il progresso del tuo spirito che
non ti allontani mai dai tuoi sogni non
allontanarti mai dai tuoi sogni e
riscalda sempre i tuoi ideali quali essi
siano e Qualunque sia la tua età perché
alla fine la cosa importante è assumere
le decisioni
e decidi sempre prendendo la decisione
che intimamente sentirai più giusta per
te ma senza avere paura di cambiare
perché cambiare rinnoverà i tuoi sogni e
rinnoverà la tua vita e ricordati se ti
sei lasciato qualcosa indietro vuol dire
che sei andato avanti
[Applauso]